Different dependencies may be needed at
different times in the build process.
Logically related dependencies
are grouped into configurations.
So far, we've be adding dependencies
to the compile configuration.
But the Java plugin creates
other configurations as well,
such as runtime, test compile,
and test runtime.
The Java plugin ensures that the
specified dependencies are on the class
path when the corresponding
tasks are run.
Dependencies can be added to any of
these configurations by simply using
the name of the configuration
followed by the dependency notation.
Here we have an added dependency
to the test compile configuration.
This dependency will only be
available from our test code.
Configurations can extend
to other configurations.
For example, test compile extends
from the compiled configuration.
Which means that all of the dependencies
in the compile configuration
are automatically
included in test compile.
We can verify this by
generating a dependency report.
Here we see that the compile
configuration contains a dependency on
commons logging.
But the test compile configuration
contains both the dependency on commons
logging and on JUnit, and
on one of its transitive dependencies.
If you have a more advanced build
with dependencies that don't fit
into a configuration
defined by the Java plugin.
You can create a custom configuration.
Just add the name of your configuration
to the configuration script block,
we can then assign dependencies
to that custom configuration.
We can now run a dependency report
to see the new dependencies
added to the Project.
And if we scroll up we find
our custom configuration
along with the dependency we declared.
Under the hood configurations
are really just fancy file collections.
And can be used anywhere a file
collection can be used such as in
a copy task.
This is useful if we want to download
some dependencies from a remote
repository and
bundle them in our project somehow.